[Müzik]
bu sene hem moderatör hem konuşmacı
olarak buradayız ve en zorlandığım kısmı
anlatmak istiyorum Ben çünkü
kendimizi tanıtalım
kendimizi tanıtma kısmı bazen içeriğin
kendisinden daha zor geliyor bana çünkü
biz kendimizi kimliklerimizle
tanımlıyoruz Kimlik nedir kimlik Aslında
topluma dönük sosyal bir yönümüzdür
kimlik sınıflandırıcıdır gruplayıcıdır
insanları kişilikse içten gelir
psikolojik bir tarafımızdır ve
kişiliğimiz bizi ayrıştırır ama biz öyle
bir sürece geldik ki sanki
kimliklerimizle sınıflanmak Bizi
Birbirimizden ayrıştırıp iletişimde
kişilikleri göz ardı ettiğimiz için bizi
birbirimizden uzaklaştırmaya başladı O
yüzden bu aralar Bu kimlik konusuna
gerçekten kafayı takmış durumdayım
Uzmanlar kimliği birçok alt Başlığa
aittir giydirilmiş kimlikler seçilmiş
kimlikler kültürel yerel ulusal ama
hepimizin hayatında yaşadığı bir 5
dakikalık sekans var bütün
kimliklerimizi orada ifşa ediyoruz
hayatın doğal akışında bunu Neredeyse
bazılarımız her gün yapıyoruz tahmin
edebilir misiniz neresi olduğunu 5
dakikada bütün kimliklerimiz
[Müzik]
Bu Kadar Kolay Olsa Çünkü
taksi dediğimizde Taksi yok O da yolcu
diye heyecanla durmuyor bir önce
debeleneceksiniz güzel Gel beğenecek mi
ikna olacak mı oraları geçelim Biz o
bilimdeki setleri böyle diğer tüm
değişkenler sabitken taksiyi
durdurabildiğimiz varsa sayalım bindik
taksiye ilk soru nedir güzergahı
söyledikten sonra kendi içinde bir
oksijen ve Paradoks falan nerelisin
hemşerim
Hemşerim zaten aynı ilde yaşayan
insanlardan ama biz de başında nerelisin
kalıbıyla kullanılır ve işte size ilk
ifşanız ulusal ve yerel kimliğiniz
nerelisiniz sorusunu yanıtı genellikle
içinde etnik bir bilgi de taşır yani
Diyarbakırlıyım Kürt müsün
hemşinliyim Laz mısın egeliyim
muhacirlik var mı hemen ikinci
Kimliğimizi Yani biz etnik Kimliğimizi
ifşa ettik bu etli kimliklerin bazıları
dini referanslar da getirir dersin
diyeyim Alevi misin akışında gerçekleşen
diyaloglar Bunlar sonra ne olur Ne iş
yapıyorsun taksici için ne İş yaptığımız
önemli bir bilgidir Biz cebindeki parası
kısıtlı Bir emekçiyiz ve birazdan trafik
yüzünden taksimetre Çok yazınca panikle
inecek miyiz Yoksa şoförü hastalandığı
için bugün taksiye mecbur kalmış ve
bahşişi bol tutacak Bir patron muyuz
Bunlar taksici için önemlidir Bunlar
Hayatın her alanında herkes için önemli
sınıfta ekonomik bilgidir bir kimliğiniz
daha ifşa oldu burada sonra ne gelir
bütün kimliğimizde de Sabıka kaydımıza
yazan Medeni halimiz Medeni halimiz
evlidir boşanmıştır duldur bekardır ve
bekar harici Tüm seçeneklerde bu soru
paket gelir ikincisi Çocuk var mı
ebeveyn kimliğiniz annemizsiniz
babamızsınız daha 2 dakikadayız şoförlü
olan muhabbetimizde peki buradan sonra
ne oluyor bakın biri serpaks satmaya
geliyor birisi camı silmeye kalkıyor
hiçbir şey olmasa trafik açılmıyor ya da
radyoda bir haber geliyor ve seçilmiş
ideoloji kimliğimiz en konuşmaya Can
attığımız şey çalıştık biz buna
birilerini ikna etmek için can atıyoruz
hemen siyasi görüşümüzü söyleyeceğiz
fikrimizi anlatacağız liberal miyiz
Sosyalist miyiz milliyetçiyiz ve Gam
mıyız vejetaryen mıyız ne olacak bu
iklimin hali taksici yanıt verecek O da
bizi ikna etmeye çalışacak dönecek gaza
gelip bana bak bayan diyecek Ben bayan
demiyoruz yalnız diyeceğim taksici
benden feminizm Vay alacak ve dönüp
diyecek ki bacım lezbiyen misin
sadece Türkiye'de yaşanan iki kavram
karışımı bu dünyanın başka hiçbir yerine
lezbiyenlikle feminizin birbirine
karışmıyor Bize Has ve orada yeni bir
kimlik karşımıza çıkıyor cinsiyet şimdi
buraya kadar taksici sordu biz
yanıtladık işte Sadece bu son kimliğimiz
daha taksi önümüzde dururken de
üzerimizdeydi kimliğin kişilikten farkı
kimlik ortama göre değiştirilebilir
kimliği içinize tutabilirsiniz söylemeye
saklamayabilirsiniz Bazı ortamlarda etli
kimliğinizi dile getirmezsiniz ya da
bazen yerel kimliğinizi atarsınız
muhatap olmak istemezsiniz demezsiniz
Ben İzmirliyim Çorumluyum dersiniz
Yozgatlıyım edirneliyim ne var
değiştirilir yani sıkıştığınızda Ama
kadınlığı değiştiremiyorsunuz o
üzerimize giyinik bir kimliğimiz
ve bizim Aslında en büyük yaramızda
buradan başlıyor çünkü toplumsal
cinsiyet rolleri dediğimiz kambur nereye
gidersek bizle birlikte geliyor Biz
taksiyi durdurduğumuzda taksici kadın
olduğumuzu biliyordu Ve bize bununla
hitap etti
biz
bu toplumda kadın olduğumuz için hep
Mazlum mahçup mağdur
narin kırılgan hassas böyle bilindik
şimdi bir gerçeklik
bir insan bedeni 45'ten acıya
dayanabilir bir kadın doğum yaparken 57
del acı çeker bu 20 kemiğin aynı anda
kırılmasına eşit bir acıdır ama
Evet sert Erkeksin sen çok haklısın
Senin ayrılık acına benim hassas kalbim
nasıl dayansın en iyisi şampiyon senin
de dediğin gibi başlamadan bitsin
Biz bir günde 35.000 karar veriyoruz
35.000 farklı karar veriyoruz bir kadın
olarak ama
aşkoların Kralı gari sana beni
beklemeden Sipariş verdiğin çok iyi oldu
çünkü ben menüden Ne yiyeceğimi nasıl
seçeceğim
Kaliforniya Üniversitesi bir araştırma
yapıyor Erkek beyni kadından altı buçuk
kat daha gri kadın beğeni ise erkek
beyninden 10 kat daha beyaz Yani net
ama yıllardır Neyi Anlatmaya çalışıyoruz
Hayır hayır demektir Emin misin diyor
gri olan sensin Ben 10 kat Hayır eminim
Çünkü benim beynim 10 kat beyaz
ve işte burada mitler yaratılıyor bu
mitler hep atergi tarafından yaratılıyor
içine kadın dahil etmiyor sanıyorlar ki
hepimiz Hastasıyız kırılganız ve
giydirilmiş rol bu toplumsal cinsiyet
rolü sadece bir davranış kalıbı
giydirmiyor bize bizi giydiriyor Biz
alışverişi ve berbere kuaföre kendi
cinsiyet rolümüzle gidiyoruz kendimiz
olarak gitmiyoruz yani şöyle düşünün O
taksiye ben dizüstü beyaz bir çizme
Giymişim bir crop top peluşta bir Türk
var üzerimde sahte
bilmiyorum ve soruyor adam ne iş
yapıyorsun
diyorum ki uluslararası ticarete genel
cerrahım siyaset bilimciyim taksi
şoförünün şekerin muamelesini
yenemezsiniz Çünkü bir kere o rolü
giymişsiniz anne kıyafeti diye bir şey
var ya estetikten yoksun beni de lastik
takmışlar Kot pantolonun ayakkabı
giyiyorsunuz burnu yuvarlak şu kadarcık
topuk tamamen Konfor olarak Konfor göz
önüne alınarak Dizayn edilmiş Niye Çünkü
siz artık bir üst kimliğe anneliğe terfi
ettiniz Artık siz Çilekeş vefakar canını
dişine takan saçı süpürge bir kadınsınız
öyle Aşk Tutku şehvet zevk ve estetik
Hani o zaman da bak full değildi ama
Geçmiş olsun Onlar kadın kimliğinizde
kaldı yani bize bir şey giydiriyor bu
toplum o kimlikle bizi sınıyor
ve şimdi size buraya kadar
anlattıklarımı Lütfen göz önüne almayın
ve politik doğruculuk yapmayın
kalbinizin sesini dinleyin objektif bir
anket yapalım 4 tane kadın internetten
bulduğum fotoğraf gösteriyorum size
diyelim ki Bir gece Çocuğunuzu bakıcı
olarak bunlardan birine bırakacaksınız
ya da havaalanındasınız kıymetli
eşyalarınız olduğu bir valiziniz var ve
1 saatliğine emanet etmeniz gerekiyor
kodluyorum
başörtülü yemenilik teyze bir yandaki
güne giden abla 2 alttaki O çok hoş
seksi leydi 3
gergin fön 4 olsun
bire bırakırım emanet ederim diyenlerin
ellerini görebilir miyim
hiç fena değil İki diyenler
herkes Gül seviyor herkes eğlenceden
yana 3
seksi oyları 4
şuna bakalım
dinlerini anlatalım Müslüman katolik
şaşırdınız mı kısır yemeğe gidiyor
Yahudi ve ateist
fikriniz değişti mi Fikri değişen var mı
hangisi diye sormayacağım değişti
şimdi bakalım diğer kimliklerine 5 çocuk
annesi 4 çocuk annesi çocuksuz İki çocuk
annesi Fikri değişen var mı
bir iki kişi çok az
Hindistan
Latin Amerikan Rus
sizin için bir şey Fark etmedi biraz
fark etti bazılarında fark ettim kim
olduklarını duymak ister misiniz
tercihlerinizin
Hindistan'da 5 çocuğuyla birlikte
yaşarken eşi pakistan'a gidiyor diyor ki
Müslümanız burada bizi katledecekler
umrum değil diyor 5 çocuğu ve ülkeyi
bırakıp bir yere gitmiyorum o ara
Hindistan'da pirinç yok diyor ki Kara
borsa pirinç işine gireceğim Tek Başına
5 çocukla karaborsa pirinç işine girip
sonra diyor ki ben Bunlar likör yapamaz
mıyım acaba likör yasak merdiven altında
likör üretmeye Başlıyor sonra o içki
sataşını diğer içkilerle yönlendiriyor
ve bir sihri var polis tarafından asla
yakalanamıyor yakalandığında delil
bulunamadığı için hemen salınılıyor
Hindistan'ın dört bir üç büyük harfleri
var üçünün de lideri erkek elini
öpüyorlar bizi birleştir büyük bir güç
alalım Biz de kolluğa karşı olmak
istiyoruz diyorlar
hayatı boyunca
[Alkış]
dalavey hayatı boyunca cezaevinde
yatmadı en uzun gözaltısı 2 ay sürdü
deli yetersizliğinden gene Salındı
sexy lady'yi beğenmediniz Moli Bloom
Amerikan
kayak takımında profesyonel olimpiyat
yarışçısıydı ve baba babasının
tercihiydi bir otoriteyle yarışları
hazırlanıyordu Bir sakatlık geçirdi ve
baba ortalığı
gireceğim ve politika okuyacağım senden
de beş kuruş para almayacağım Yakamdan
düş Baba gittiğinde para kazanmak için
bir adamın yanında kurup yerliye başladı
Sonra dedi ki bu çok gelişi çok kolay
Bunu ben niye kendim yapmayayım ki
Hollywood yıldızları dünyanın en büyük
iş insanları
siyasetçiler bazı ülkelerin bakanları
kaçaklar Amerika'nın 5 yıldızlı en
pahalı otellerinde giriş ücreti 250 bin
dolardan başlayan illegal poker masaları
kurdurdu peşine FBI düştü sizin Reza
Zarrab davasından hatırlayacağınız Bahar
Hanım ünlü olduğu davadır voleybolumun
davası FBI ile bir anlaşma yaptı
cezaevinde yatmadı Bu fotoğrafta bekar
ve çocuksuz da 44 yaşında ilk çocuğunu
doğurdu bir nörobilimci ile evlendi ve
Hiç ceza yatmadığı gibi her şeyini
kaybettikten sonra FBI ile Uzlaşmak
adına yepyeni bir işe başladı sahnelerde
kinox spier'lık yapıyor konuşmacı olarak
ekmeğini kazanıyor
fönlüye hiç oy vermediniz Valentine
48 tur attı 3 gün sürdü ve o zamana
kadar tüm Amerikalı kozmonotların uzayda
geçirdiği sürenin toplamından daha
fazlaydı Neil armstrong'un uzayda aya
gidip ayak basması ondan 6 yıl sonraydı
Valentine theresova Normalde Boydan
fotoğrafını görseniz madalyaları buradan
başlıyor diz kapaklarının altına iniyor
bir halk kahramanı sovyetlerde komünist
partinin Merkez komitesinde yer aldı
Birleşmiş Milletler ve dünya kadın
konferanslarında Sovyetler birliğini
temsil etti siyaseti hiç bırakmadı şu an
putin'in yer aldığı Rusya'da hala Rusya
sana organı Duma da yetkili Neden Çünkü
Putin
Valentine karşısına almaya korktu böyle
bir halk kahramanı düşmanınız olarak
lanse edemezsiniz her ne kadar kadın
ateist ve komünist olsa da yaşamada
kendisine bir rol vermek zorunda mısınız
çok sevdiğiniz
griselde Blanco Hazır mısınız
kristalda Latin dedim Niye anlamadınız
Kolombiyalı Amerika'da çok meşhur Çünkü
medellin kartelinin karadull lakaplı
lideridir bir milyar dolarlık bir kokain
ticaretinde aylık cirosu 80 milyon
dolardır
birebir parmağı olan tespit edilebilen
cinayet sayısı 200'dür bunlardan 3'ü
eski kocalarıdır
[Alkış]
ama baktığınızda
giydirilmiş kıyafetler giydirilmiş
kimlikler kişiliklerin yanında ne kadar
saçma kaldı değil mi
Şimdi şöyle düşünelim Bu kadınlar İdeal
mi
değil
there bile ideal değildi çünkü sen
Sovyet rusyasında komünist partinin
mkasından kalkıp putin'in doğum gününe
özel davetli olarak gidemezsin yani o
bile ideal değil ama objektif olarak
bunlar güçlü kadınlar Bunlar hükümet
deviren kadınlar Bunlar Kartel kuran
kadınlar Bunlar milyar doları ile gay
yöneten kadınlar Çünkü güç yasal Bir
zemin aramaz Biz zaten buna çok iyi
sınandık hepimiz takdir edersiniz ki
diye sunulan İmge ne Biz güçlü kadınlar
ne anlıyoruz eşitliği en çok
konuştuğumuz 8 mart'ların kamu
spotlarına kurumsal reklamlarına gelin
otobüs kullanan kadın pilot
forklift kullanıyor kadın kadın Cerrah
güçlü
güçlü güçlü dümdüz meslek ya sınavına
giriyorsunuz
okulunu okuyorsunuz meslek işte
veriyorlar yapıyorsunuz ya Bu niye güç
oluyor yani soruyu şöyle soralım ya da
biz neden
en ufak hayata tutunma başarımızda güçlü
olmak zorunda kalıyoruz niye biz bir
kamyonu sürebileceğimizi ikna etmek için
efor sarf etmek zorunda kalıyoruz niye
Biz hayatın akışında durduk yere
yapılması gerekeni yapıp diğer adamlar
gibi normal sayılamıyoruz Biz niye
normali yaşamak için güçlü olmak
zorundayız ve diğer bir soru niye biz
güçsüzken Hayat akışında bizi ayakta
tutamıyor bir diğer temel kaygımızda bu
Biz
biz gücü yanlış yerde arıyoruz bize
dayatılan hep bir mükemmeliyetçilik var
bizden beklenen ne ekonomik
bağımsızlığımızı elimizde tutacağız ama
bunu yaparken eğer evde başka bir erkek
varsa onun egosuna da saldırmayacağız
çocuğumun çocuğun tüm bakımından ve
okulla olan ilişkilerinden ve sağlık
kontrollerinden sorumluyuz bunu yaparken
de uzun süreli ilişkide tutkuyu ayakta
tutmak için partlarımıza küçük hoş
erotik sürprizler hazırlayacağız Ve
tabii ki bakımlı olmayı bırakmayacağız
işimize çok iyi çalışacağız kendimizi
ispat edeceğiz gözümüzü çok fazla
yükseklere dikmeyeceğiz patavatsızca
konuşmayacağız yöneticilere suyuna
gideceğiz ve eğer her şey yolundaysa
bize diyecekler ki iyi kadın
güçlü kadın
bu mu ya biz sizin en ufak
takdirlerinize layık olabilmek için her
şey dört dörtlük yapmak zorunda mıyız
her şey tırnaklarımızla kazıyıp her
şeyde mükemmel olmak zorunda mıyız Değil
başarılı kadının mükemmellikle eşlenmesi
toplumda makbul görülen kadın kimliği
için mükemmel olmanız gerekiyor biz
sizin kimliğinizin bize biçtiği
giysilere sığmak zorunda mıyız
biz normal Sıradan insanlar erkekler
gibi yaşayamaz mıyız bir insan ataerki
ve bu düzen bizi korkuyla sınıyor
yargıda adaletsizlik yaftalamada
izahsızlık toplumda dışlanma sürekli bir
korku içerisindeyiz ve bu korku
bizi Hata yapmaktan
dehşete düşürüyor hata yapmamanın yolu
nedir yapmamak denememek yani motor
ehliyet sınavına girmemek teknede
yaşamaya kalkmamak dünyayı gezmeye
niyetlenmemek Çünkü üzerimizde bir korku
İmparatorluğu var çünkü bize giydirilmiş
bir kadın kimliği bir makbul kadın
giysisi var çünkü kimlikler üzerinden
korku salmak çok kolay
Çünkü cesaret bir kişilik özelliğidir
bir kimlik özelliği değil o yüzden bu
düzenin korkularımız işine geliyor
kimliği giydirip kimliklerimizle
yargılamak Bu sistemin işine geliyor
Dolayısıyla
Taksiden inerken
ne şeyle el mi sallıyoruz yoksa bazı
kimliklerde ihtimal dahilinde
uzlaşabildiğimiz taksiciyle
ya da uzlaşamadığımız taksiciyle parayı
Alka koltuğa fırlatıp kapıyı çarpıp
plakasını alıp Koşuyor muyuz bunu
belirleyen kimlik ve bizim diyaloğu
yönetebilme
iyi iletişim kurabilme gibi kişilik
özelliklerimiz mi bakın kişilik
geliştirilebilir ama ağına göre iradeyi
değiştirilemez Çünkü kimlikten çok daha
güçlüdür O yüzden şimdi başta yapmam
gereken
kendini tanıtma işini
ben en sonunda yapayım istiyorum
Ben
dayatılan tüm kimliklerin ayrı ayrı
kavgasını vermekten
bakmamış da yorulmuş
Her şeye inat Yaşasın Hayat
şiarıyla mutluluk devşirmek mevzusunda
bazen absürtleşmiş
Coğrafya kaderdir bizde kaderdir
algısına inat ortalamanın üstü umutlu
Orantısız coşkulu
zaman zaman endişeli
Görece neşeli biraz Alemci bir kişiyim
gün gelmiş fabrikada işçi gün gelmiş Bir
kadın girişimci
günü gelmiş Gazetede köşe dergide Öykü
Yayınevi sordukça kitap yazmış
eşitlik Adalet özgürlük gibi eylemlerde
aktivist olarak yer almış ve gelen anlat
denildiğinde katıldığı söyleşilerde bunu
anlatmış yazdım ve okuduğum kadar
Edebiyattan da Dem vurmuş biriyim
okulunu okuduğum için siyaset bilimci
ekmeğimi kazandığım için iletişimci
iki cevvalin yetebildiği kadar annesi
yemek Çamaşır bulaşık sağlıklı beslenme
Bir nevi ev yemekçisi
iş verilirse moderatör layık görülürsem
konuşmacı Ne iş olsa yaparım
hayatta
mutlu olmak ve özgür olmak için Hata
yapmaktan korkmayı bıraktım
ve sürekli makbullük sınavlarından
kalıyorum ve bu başarısızlığım çok
seviyorum Yeter ki hayatlarımız onurlu
ve iyilikler yana olsun diyorum
sürçülisan ettiysem affola teşekkürler